et bien il nous reste un petit peu de
temps pour notre dernier sujet alors
c'est un peu avoue vers vous que je vais
me tourner mathieu bock côté les
musulmans célèbrent aujourd'hui la fin
du ramadan le figaro consacre deux pages
de main à l'islam de france un islam de
france qu'on sait en crise un islam qu
emmanuel macron pourtant pleins
d'ambitions au début de son quinquennat
peine à structurer alors tout ça on va
en parler mais d'abord je voudrais qu'on
s'arrête sur votre chronique mathieu
bock-côté que le figaro a publié ce
week-end vous y parlez d'un livre
intitulé histoire de l'islamisation
française c'est paru aux éditions de
l'artilleur et vous dites il est
certainement indispensable aujourd'hui
de faire des lois contre la burqa dans
la rue et le hidjab à l'école mais il
n'est pas normal que cela soit devenu
nécessaire est également cette phrase
qui s'affiche la multiplication des lois
pour contraindre l'islam à se plier aux
moeurs françaises relève mois d'une
volonté politique en fait affirmé que
d'un affaiblissement du corps social
en clair vous dites la pression du corps
social suffisait pour que les étrangers
s'assimile ce n'est plus le cas en effet
pour différentes raisons c'est à dire
d'un côté la poussée de l'individualisme
là le poids ou si l'immigration c'est à
dire michel brunel historiens québécois
disaient que trois facteurs pesant
l'histoire le nombre le nombre et le
nombre va partir de certains seuils
d'intégration s'est plus difficilement
ensuite la culture anti discriminatoire
entre guillemets skate en sorte que
plusieurs des processus sociaux qui
traditionnellement fait en sorte qu'on
avait tout intérêt à s'intégrer à
s'assimiler aux pays d'accueil
eh bien ces pressions sociales sont
neutralisés au nom de ce qu'on appelle
de manière à revient à ce que vous
disiez précisément la logique de
lentilles discrimination et quelquefois
elles relèvent en fait du
multiculturalisme donc tout a été fait
de manière où l'on s'est souvent porté
par l'europe d'ailleurs dont tout a été
fait pour neutraliser les processus
naturels d'assimilation et là quelques
fonds sur un compte ça ne fonctionne
plus faut au moins envoyer un signal
politique comme quoi on veut même dans
l'intégration la sélection sur le voile
à l'école dosnon qu'elles sont
nécessaires mais il est dommage que les
processus sociaux ne soit plus suffisant
ne fonctionne plus donc oui il faudra
ensuite la volonté politique est
indispensable mais sachant néanmoins que
c'est un symptôme des puissances
néanmoins paradoxalement alors le
paradoxe enfin le
le suisse matthias et que finalement
cette pression sociale dans les
quartiers où c'est plutôt les salafistes
qui l'exercent
oui mais là pour moi la première chose
que j'ai envie de dire c'est que on a
quand même plusieurs millions de nos
compatriotes qui sont musulmans qui
pratiquent leur foi et ça se passe bien
ça se passe bien il n'y a pas de
problèmes majeurs liés à la pratique de
l'islam en france
alors ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas
un certain nombre de questions à régler
mais je pense que ce ce premier point
est quand même très important à à mettre
en avant
alors après par contre oui il y avait
question réglée est ce que ces questions
peuvent être réglés d'en haut par l'état
je ne le crois pas je ne crois pas parce
que l'islam de france est traversée par
des courants extrêmement opposés et
concurrents il ya le courant algérien le
courant marocain le courant des pays du
golfe le courant tueur et que espérer
faire émerger une autorité rassembleuse
incontestable et incontesté qui
organiserait l'islam de france je n'y
crois pas par contre il y à delhi à des
questions très concrètes à régler par
exemple la formation des imams
la formation des imams c'est ça c'est un
vrai sujet la très grande majorité des
imams de france aujourd'hui sont
algériens marocains turcs égyptien ça
pose sa pose pas seulement des problèmes
de doctrine
ça pose aussi des problèmes y compris
parce que beaucoup d'entre eux par
exemple aujourd'hui sont en situation
irrégulière administratives doivent
quitter le territoire français pour les
remplacer c'est très compliqué il ya des
pressions qui s'exercent et a donc ça
avoir des des imams français ça ça
serait une très bonne chose et la
deuxième est le deuxième point qu'il
faut régler c'est le problème de la de
la régularisation des salles de prières
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
normalement il devrait y avoir une
autorité qui disent ce lieu est reconnu
comme un lieu de culte et ce lieu ne
l'est pas alors qu'aujourd'hui on est on
est souvent dans le flou et les maires
doivent se débrouiller avec ça et c'est
pas toujours facile
je vous laisse encore deux secondes pour
compass leçons d' emmanuel macron
c'était lors de la conférence de presse
à l'élise la fin du grand débat où il
revenait
et justement on va voir le changement de
ton en tout cas du président sur ces
questions il ne parle plus vraiment de
réformer l'islam de france
l'écouté parle plus de la question du
financement quand on parle de laïcité
on ne parle pas vraiment de laïcité on
parle du communautarisme qui s'est
installée dans certains quartiers de la
république
et là dessus j'ai demandé au
gouvernement d'être intraitable donc
commencé à le faire avec une politique
ambitieuse de reconquête républicaine
dans plusieurs quartiers se souhaite que
nous allions plus loin en renforçant le
contrôle sur les financements venant de
l'étranger en étant beaucoup plus dur à
l'égard de toutes les formes de cet
islamisme politique de ce
communautarisme de cette session au sein
de notre république parce que c'est une
menace sur la capacité à tenir la nation
ensemble il a réduit ses ambitions à la
baisse alors emmanuel macron celle
affichée il a surtout vous le disiez
raison changer ton il ya une expression
qu'on voit pas dans cet extrait c'est
qu'ils parlent pas seulement d'islamisme
politique ce qui est une évidence il
parle aussi de l'islam politique et ça
c'est plus intéressant et ça emmanuel
macron été très frileux pour le faire
avant d'être élu et au début de son
quinquennat
est-ce qu'il a revu ses ambitions à la
baisse oui il voulait à la base réformer
la loi 1905 tout changer tout chambouler
tout régler c'est que c'est un peu dans
ses habitudes de vouloir toujours tout
régler ici il s'est aperçu que ça ça
sera un peu plus compliqué que prévu et
donc il se concentre sur le financement
c'est un des indépendants ton monte en
parallèle le financement et puis en
effet y aura près les questions de
formation des imams de langue des
prêches et c'est l'autre juin sujet à
peu emmanuel mais sensible il va ça
l'était déjà mais disons qu'il ya eu une
prise de conscience au sein de
l'exécutif
celui qui a peut-être un peu vrai à ça
je sais pas dans quelle mesure ça on le
saura avec un bus de recul c'est gérard
collomb gérard collomb faut se rappeler
des mots qu'ils emploient avant de
quitter la place beauvau nous vivons
aujourd'hui
côte à côte nous risquons demain de
vivre face à face son regard était
facile à suivre
alexine je crois que macro comme ses
prédécesseurs le lui a fallu deux ans
pour sortir du syndrome bonaparte
tous les présidents de la république
pachira qui voulait s'occuper surtout de
rien
encore que à un moment il a essayé avec
dunkerque
boubakeur effectivement mais ça drôme
n'a pas ses rangs on va regagner parce
que ça ne va pas cet islam pour toutes
les raisons que vous dites on va
organiser tout ça l'état on va faire une
religion d'état comme bonaparte avait
avec les juifs le grand sanhédrin on va
les réunir on va les mettre dans une
salle on va dire toi tu fais ça tu fais
ça on tue va nommer tête et imams comme
si c'était des prêtres avec des
des autorités tutorat droit de dire ça
tu auras un catéchisme
ils ont tous essayé sarkozy s'est donné
un mal de voleurs pour essayer ça
évidemment ça n'a pas marché il une
lutte allait jusqu à les enfermer pour
essayer de les mettre d'accord
évidemment pas bonnes hollande acier
vaguement mais comme il faisait beaucoup
de choses vont empirer prudemment
relancée et et makro ici aussi puis il
s'est rendu compte à l'évidence ça ne
marche pas pour toutes les raisons que
je viens de dire ce que j'ai ce matin
autant je ne suis pas d'accord avec le
constat le diagnostic initial du ca que
dire que le le communautarisme ou la
pratique de l'islam ne pose pas de
problème notre pays évidemment ça pose
un double problème autant sur le ce
qu'il a dit dans un deuxième temps qui
était de dire essayer de l'état prenne
tout ça en main pour organiser ça ne
marche pas donc il faut surtout pas s'en
mêler
ils savent faut simplement poser des
règles et faire en sorte que les règles
soient respectées que les prêches que
les imams respectives de loi que les
financements respecter sont de loi et
que les prêches reste dans certaines
limites voilà point barre et puis il
faut surtout pas se mêler de rien sinon
c'est une sorte d'engrenage où chaque
fois les pouvoirs publics et son père
dans nos internautes ils sont assez
partagés le gouvernement doit-il
organisé l'islam de france vous demander
ton oui à 52% une très légère majorité
babineau nous dit le gouvernement ne
pourra jamais réellement cadres et les
musulmans de france l'islam est trop
complexe et trop intime pour certains
mathieu bock-côté une question par
exemple d'actualité récente le sénat a
dit que les mères voilées ne pouvait pas
accompagner les sorties scolaires des
enfants bonne chose bosses après partie
de ces règles qu'il faut établir où ça
va trop loin dans le jeu je crois que la
france doive céder absolument rien sur
la question de la laïcité il me semble
et c'est à dire aujourd'hui il y à la
france pour peu qu'on compare deux
grands modèles s'agir de côté
multiculturel et sur l'anglo saxonne et
de l'autre côté de la laïcité à la
française je pense qu'il ya une
légitimité aujourd'hui à demander une
laïcisation légitimement fait de
l'espace public non pas pour contrôler
la vie des uns des autres non pas pour
contrôler les expressions de la foi mais
pour éviter tout simplement les
débordements des communautarismes dans
l'espace public au nom du langage des
droits de l'homme parce que le véritable
enjeu derrière simple c'est la
récupération par le communautarisme
islamique du langage des droits de
l'homme pour normaliser des
revendications et non communautaire sous
le signe des dons
10 visuel et ça on le voit chez nous
c'est au nom des droits individuels que
le niqab se normalise alors je note que
partout l'islamisme a appris à parler le
langage nos sociétés et si nous ne
sommes pas capables de répondre à ce
langage si on se laisse bluffé par
quelques mots nous sommes condamnés
insultes avaient puissance politique je
vous de poser la question d'honneur gym
devrait pas vraiment répondu sur cette
pression salafistes elle s'exerce
effectivement elle est quotidienne c'est
pas tellement aujourd'hui la pression
des autres communautés c'est à
l'intérieur de la communauté musulmane
que la pression elle existe existe il
faut pas laisser une réalité d'abord il
est très surveillée il faut quand même
le dire elle est très surveillée elle et
elle est lé contenu vous peut dire
qu'avant tel est bien sûr gouaille a pu
lé contenu parce que la grande majorité
de nos concitoyens musulmans ne sont
absolument pas dans cette logique là
absolument pas ils veulent vivre un
islam intégré tranquille qui ne soit pas
qui ne pose aucun problème à la
république c'est l'état d'esprit moi je
vous invite à avenue si vous voulez
venez à nanterre je vous montrerai
comment ça se passe à nanterre dans les
trois mosquées que nous avons à nanterre
et vous verrez que la malle la
description que vous faites
extrêmement fantasmée de cette réalité
ça ne correspond ça ne correspond pas
parce que quand vous voyez des
manifestation communautariste dans tous
les coins c'est votre fantasme dans ce
que j'ai dit est une inquiétude
communautariste légitime en france a
tous moi même dans les trois mois je
vous dis voilà vous venez dans ma ville
et là où on a une preuve une population
musulmane qui est pas qui est importante
et vous verrez que le vivre ensemble
c'est une réalité s'adressent à des bras
non mais il faut il faut faire la part
des choses mais jean laffon éviter il
faut éviter les amalgames parce que moi
moi je vous répète alors oui il ya un
certain nombre de risques
le danger salafistes il est là il y lire
il est réel mais un il est surveillé de
la majorité des musulmans ne veut pas de
cette dérive là elle s'y oppose et et
donc il faut il faut traiter les choses
avec une certaine sérénité est pas sans
arrêt mettre de l'huile sur le feu et ai
pensé qu' on a là un péril à nos pauvres
n'ont jusqu'ici pas la mort non
je ne crois pas le rapport d'hakim el
karoui tous à ses côtés pour un bon
moment à l'elysée pour l'instant il ya
d'autres priorités à l'elysée en tout
cas politiquement il ya d'autres
priorités
pour emmanuel macron que cette question
là dans le calendrier de ce qui arrive
au moins jusqu'à la fin de l'année
c'est pas ce qui est en haut d'un an au
dagestan à d'autres on aura d'autres
sujets pour point de vue à vendre par
norauto sujets principalement
économiques on m'a parlé de tala et puis
y aura peut-être aussi la question de la
bioéthique qui risque d'être aussi
sensible et d'arrivée peut-être avant et
donc est la question que vous posez sur
lefigaro.fr le gouvernement doit-il
organisé l'islam de france vous êtes 50
2% à répondre oui